I've unplugged when I go run no more
stimulus I forgot what running felt like
there was always something I was trying
to get out of it outside of and like I
was just over stimulating I went for a
run and I literally was just listening
to my breath my foot falls the birds it
like reminded me of me as a kid running
that's what I love about running like
moving through space quickly kind of
feeling effortless and floating letting
everything go letting go of the control
not thinking getting rid of that
analysis by paralysis that's where
you're going to get produce your best
work whatever it is if you're an artist
or an athlete or in medicine I feel like
you do have to let go that control stop
thinking and Trust the process